[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine ebooks ne supportant ni
moins des bois ni petit robert décide de
partir en espagne pour tenter sa chance
auprès de berlusconi
le directeur de la sixième chaîne ou bts
[Musique]
joby ça va
depuis damas
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a mis la dynamique mais je suis dit
katie katie qui apaise qui fait suite au
real bayonne prend garde parce que tous
les ordres en garde
mon cas n'est pas son nom c'est pas
grave ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
ah oui depuis le temps que je rêve tu
sais ce que fait la vache est en théorie
à l'ol ferait bien oui
avant cela il faut que je te présente
maman elle-même madre il était présente
ma fiancée m'a fait la princesse de
monaco
non mais non mais non c'est la princesse
animaux maman est innocent voyant delà
des problème de carburateur l'âge au
mariage et l'épouser il aime tous à malo
montlignon courant tout qu'est la vienne
remarquez monaco je vais pas penser qu'à
des princes
[Musique]